welcome everyone it's a meme so when we
go ahead and get started
my name is Maggie Peters and I'm an
assistant professor here in the
political science department might be
great honor and introducing David
Leighton today um thank you all so much
for coming so this is the third and
final castle lecturers development in
Africa entitled a search for causes why
is Africa been the final frontier for
this last lecture instead of talking
about all of David's great scholarly
work I want to talk about David as a
mentor and his work in the profession as
a mentor um
Jamie's mentorship I think is
particularly relevant to this lecture
because it's on the causes that no one
scholar could ever hope to determine all
the causes and all the effects of
development or lack thereof and so it
takes an army of scholars to actually do
this um and David has mentored several
people who are now working in this field
so I first met David as a first-year
graduate student at Stanford when I took
his comparative politics seminar having
studied international relations in
college I had no idea who David Laden
was or like he was the you know being
and important in the field or anything
like that
um and honestly that that first semester
David was quite terrifying because you
seem to know everything about everything
like anytime you brought up a plane he's
like no actually this happened and
you're like oh no I I know what Eddie I
don't know anything I'm just a
first-year um but what was great about
that class is that he took our ideas
really seriously so when you move a
logically coherent and you know well
argued point David actually took it
seriously and engaged with it as a
serious scholar would not just taking
like oh you're first your classroom you
don't really know what you're talking
about but instead really engaging with
those ideas later that's a mirror I also
had the opportunity to take his methods
and comparative politics workshop in
which each student posed a research
project and we workshop it throughout
the quarter I was really astonished by
his enthusiasm for students ideas and
insights he would express a genuine
excitement at the prospects of his
students not only advancing his own work
in the work of other scholars but even
overturning it but I quickly learned new
about David from this and other
interaction
that he tastes the ideas of younger
scholars quite seriously
Davis is really the best kind of mentor
and he served on my committee so I got
to see this firsthand because he
actually believes he can learn from his
advisees as much as they can learn from
him just the other night at dinner
so last Wednesday went out to dinner he
was discussing the work of one of his
current crop of graduate students and
her work in Africa just as he would
discuss any work of like any senior
scholar really engaging with it
seriously and telling us how important
it was and what a big contribution it
would make to the literature so this is
one of the reasons um I think that his
work has remained so relevant and
important over time he's continuing
eager to learn from his students even as
he shapes them into social scientists
and I believe that one of his most
lasting legacies will be the army of
scholars that he's developed including
myself AB and he has taught us to
examine really big questions that maybe
don't have easy answers or maybe don't
have easy research designs but are big
and important for the world and how to
get at good quality research to try and
get at those answers to those questions
so without further ado here is David Lee
Yipes Thank You Maggie
so the organization of the lectures
lecture one was on the unfulfilled
dreams of African independence where I
took the goals of what the 1960 era
would bring and showed that on three
major dimensions that of economic
development health of social order and
of democracy Africa did not move in the
direction of other post-colonial regions
or other regions of the world but
diverged from it and its development on
these three dimensions was nowhere close
to the hopes of the founding charismatic
generation
lecture to ice I think of as the
symptoms of this failure from the
culture of failed cultural
jack'd of african personality Negritude
to the to the breakdowns of social order
through military rule first by armies
and then by personalist dictatorships
and what personalism has meant so the
and third the levels of corruption
prebendal ism the ownership of officers
and how that has constrained economic
development all of these were the
symptoms of this failure of African
Dreams and this lecture is a search for
causes why has Africa been the final
frontier and one slide of an addendum
with bringing some hope after a lecture
of the causes of the lag in development
on these three outcomes as I said in the
end of the second lecture foreshadowing
this one that so far I've shown some
associations that is between African
politics or processes and its failures
on things we care about
but for establishing causes you want to
do something more you want to show
something that's exaggerated
appreciative cause cannot be influenced
by the outcome to be explained we need
to show the presence of cause was in a
sense as if randomly assigned to say
this was a this was an outside effect a
cause which led to the effects which
lecture one points to and from the
literature
I basically parceled out eight different
you can call them story lines narratives
in which we see some independent effect
of each of these accounts on some at
least some or at least one of the
outcome
factors that the first lecture pointed
to so just look it over and I will go
one by one through these different
accounts and unfortunately there is no
literature out there which weighs the
particular magnitude of each of these
effects nor is there literature which
says which particular effect is related
to which particular cause so these are
more generalized causal accounts for why
Africa is on the final frontier one of
them was really you could say motivated
by some basic research by a Yale PhD who
then had to go down the status ladder to
teach a Princeton Geoffrey Hearst and he
pointed out that African geography and
demographic patterns has had a big
effect on Africa being the last frontier
what he did was distinguished four kinds
of demographic patterns across African
states from difficult geographies large
countries with non contiguous areas of
high population density ten of the 38
countries which he examined meet the
criteria of difficult hinterland
countries populations concentrated in a
very small area with the rest being
sparsely large and sparsely populated
four of his 38 cases favorable
geographies smaller countries with
populations contract concentrated around
the capital that's about half the
countries and then neutral the residual
for which he has no predictions so let's
look at these four different geographies
here is the DRC which he calls difficult
you can see in the darker areas high
population density with vast areas of
extremely low density making it
extremely difficult to move from or to
to transport from one major center to
another and from the point of view of
herps more so when we get to the
hinterland countries that from the point
of view of the colonial leaders who try
to govern these territories or the
independence leaders the cost of getting
to these other regions is higher than
the returns of actually bringing order
so in a sense from a rational
perspective bringing order to areas far
from the capital city is not going to
yield you very much because in the sense
sending administrators out there and
actually being able to oversee them was
too closely a costly here comes the
hinterland countries and example of
mauritania and you see the tremendous
possibility as we'll see in a few
moments that if you have small
populations here that in the sense
recruit ethnic in of for an insurgent
army actually getting out there is no
easy task so let them and the French did
this and the independence leaders did
this is let them wallow in their poverty
and maybe will face some insurgency
later on but the costs of actually
governing these areas is too high the
favourable political geographies an
example of Benin is shows how relatively
easy it is to go from south to north
populations are reasonably high all the
way up and therefore there's the car the
costs of sending administrators to the
north of the country is much lower than
then it would be in the hinterland
countries to its north neutral political
geographies here's an example of Uganda
for which we have nothing to say the the
pattern here of the difficult terrains
the Sahel being the hinterland gives you
a sense that African geography has some
can continue continuity across the
different state
so what do we learn and this is
something that herps didn't do but we're
going to be doing more once we develop
clear criteria for coding countries on
this dimension of difficult and in
hinterland basically because herps
didn't code them and we're developing
coding criteria independent independent
of the peeking on the outcome variables
which I think Herbst did so or he
couldn't avoid doing but now we have GIS
data and satellite data which is
enabling us to develop clear coding
criteria for every country in the world
project being done amongst my graduate
students now so if you look here at gdb
per cat starting in 1960 what you'll see
is the it's the basically the hinterland
countries and and also the here the
neutral but it's the favorable geography
countries which somehow have done a
great deal better in in GDP GDP growth
so you could say if you once put in
dummies for each of the political
geographies the Africa the Africa effect
on GDP growth would go way down so you
could say that having a bad geography
rather than being in Africa is a is a
causal factor what we find for
probability of civil war the difficult
terrains
are the ones that have the highest
probability of a civil war and the
reason that for that is you have these
autonomous largely populated areas
outside the purview of the capital city
that are better able to mount an
insurgency so difficult terrains are
connected with the probability of civil
war and and this is a interesting work
coming from another PhD student at
Stanford who's now at University of
Pittsburgh Luke Andre
what he did is he looked at for all
ethnic groups in Africa
he took the center of where their
population was and the distance from the
capital city and then he looked at the
data from the minorities at risk and
also a clad for levels of rebellion and
asked the question what's the
probability of rebellion based upon
distance from the capital city and in a
sense if you're in a difficult or
difficult or a hinterland distance from
the capital is a very strong predictor
of of the group being in rebellion
against this ethnic group being in
rebellion against a state whereas in
favorable and neutral geographies
there's no relationship of distance to
the capital and rebellion so we're
really seeing an effect of the inability
of states to to bring you could call it
control or governance to areas that are
very very difficult to reach given the
peculiar nature nature of African
geography another aspect of geography of
course is distance from the equator and
and what we find in distance from the
equator as we're going to get to this
later on when we talk about ethnic
linguistic fractionalization but right
now we can just give you a simple graph
showing that the average latitude of the
country in sub-saharan Africa and the
prediction of the probability of malaria
and that is to say that as you are
closer to the equator the probability
the the probability of malaria of
contracting malaria goes up so to sort
of summarize this number one factor
difficult geography and proximity
proximity to the equator are associated
with low growth peripheral rebellion and
poor health to use the language of
statistics it
it's reducing the Africa the effect of
the Africa dummy on growth equation the
work of Nathaniel Nathan none on the
slave trade is remarkable in the 1950s
and 1960s a set of historians who call
themselves Klee electricians Philip
Curtin at University of Wisconsin was
one of the leaders started doing
censuses of the slave trade and they had
these historians had no right hand side
variables in mind and no left-hand side
variables in mind all they thought about
was we want to know the facts of how
many slaves there were and what ethnic
groups they were and it looked something
like this with a transatlantic slave
trade of about ten million slaves an
Indian Ocean about a million
trans-saharan three million red seat 1.3
million and they not only were able to
get the size of the the slave trade the
magnitude of it but also through all
sorts of other records about facial
facial markings they were able to get
the ethnicity of the groups as well or
ethnicity of the slaves as well and get
a pretty good idea of where they were
from and it looks something like this
with the numbers of of today's country
of those countries didn't exist during
the slave trade but you're able to
attribute where the slaves were from
based upon their ethnicity and from
where the port from which they were
exported and then the question is what
is the relationship between high levels
of slave export in the country that
exists today on things we care about
today and it turns out from amazing
statistical work the
by nathan none and someone who taught
here for several years
leonard want chicken turns out to be
pretty substantial so what we find is
that if you just take the log slave
exports over area of the country and
just take those blow and above the
median number of slaves and we look at
average per capita income what we see
astonishingly is a tremendous effect of
the slave trade on post-independence
growth it says nothing about growth up
to 1960 but after 1960 when Africans
themselves were ruling something
happened which which made the slave
export countries diverge from the from
the non slave export countries from from
the median which is pretty astonishing
and there is a reversal of fortune so if
you again which is basically shows this
by country that the higher the log the
higher log exports the lower the per
capita income in 2000 but what's what's
astonishing is the paper with none and
Montek on one of the things we know from
afro barometer a survey instrument used
periodically through the African
continent a number of African countries
are associated is they asked a set of
questions about do you trust your
relatives do you trust your neighbors
you trust the local council and a
generalized trust country question in
general do you trust people and what is
astonishing as this has done across the
whole world that high levels of trust
associate with better levels of public
goods and higher growth so the fact that
we can go into a Toyota dealership and
just show a piece of plastic and they're
willing to accept it lowers transactions
costs in the economy and and somehow
this piece of plastic on averages can is
considered where does this guy probably
does have the money to buy a thing you
look at the levels of
trust and and log exports and what you
see the higher the higher the level of
exports the lower levels of trust which
is sort of a causal factor for low
levels of public goods and low growth
and this holds up when none and logic on
send their articles to economics
journals everyone says this can't be
true
I'm one of the reviewers myself and said
this can't be true and they have scores
of of estimations with everyone's
favorite omitted variable and this thing
holds up why it's holding up and how few
centuries lay there the effect still
holds is something that we really don't
understand but we have to try to
understand because the distrust
inherited distrust from the slave trade
seems to have been or seems to be an
important factor in explaining why
Africa is the last frontier and
certainly the slave trade at this
magnitude distinguishes Africa from the
other continents of the world third
factor partition I love this next
picture
this is developing the Treaty of Berlin
in in 1884 in 1885 and you can look at
the ethnicity of the people who are
dividing Africa and you get a good sense
of the local knowledge they had when
when they made the boundaries of Africa
oh I'll get to this later but I can't
hold myself back now
Alberto Alcina has this wonderful
algorithm and says that the the
percentage of the country's borders at
which or a straight line are in effect
are are an indication that these borders
would not endogenous ly develop based
upon political power but exogenously
imposed which means that the place is
not real in the sense of having come
from its own internal processes and
those of you who don't know Nevada will
appreciate a given under understanding
so the Berlin conference from November
84 to 90 1885 to determine the
boundaries basically the Congo Free
State principally to prevent conflict
amongst Europeans that was the basic
goal Africa wasn't worth fighting over
so let's get boundaries so we won't have
to fight each other and if you haven't
read africanist who haven't read
Robinson and Gallagher on this Africa
and the Victorians I strongly recommend
it to understand imperialism from a
different point of view from the one
that Lenin has suggested the consequence
was to lay down principles for the
partition of Africa and as you saw from
the previous slide no African leaders
were involved one first-hand account
we've been engaged in drawing lines upon
maps where no white man's feet have ever
toured I don't know what that means we
have been giving away mountains and
rivers and lakes to each other only
hindered by the small impediment that we
never knew exactly where the mountains
and rivers and lakes were
this is quoted in this fabulous paper by
mikela Poulos and Papa now in looking at
the secondary effects of the partition
something I rely upon so the map was
divided more or less this way but more
interestingly connected to the work of
George Murdoch one of the greatest
anthropologists to have worked with
African material and here worked here at
Yale was each of these colors represents
a different ethnic group in his in his
data set and then superimposed on that
is the boundaries of Africa States today
and we see as you'll see in a moment no
relationship whatsoever to the core
areas of ethnic homogeneity and the
actual boundaries if you go through the
partition groups from the egg ba in
Nigeria Benin and Togo where we're at
most 50 percent of their homeland is in
a single country that you can go down
about 15 or 20 different ethnic groups
more or less than 50 percent to show how
many groups have been divided in half
across of African borders I say at the
end for those of you who are political
scientists Africans Africa's problems
may be a gift of social science allowing
for really well identified cross-border
regression discontinuity designs as
exploited by Dan Posner in looking at a
group two groups separated by the
Zambian and Malawi and Malawi border the
che was and kombuchas which says the che
wasn't the Buccos have a different
percentage of the overall population of
their country in the two different
countries what's the effect of being a
smaller or larger minority on how they
see themselves ethnically it's a
terrific paper in the American Political
Science Review and a gift to us from
Berlin 1884 1885
very small gift this comes basically
from Nikolas and Papa now's data but you
look at the groups that were not
partitioned and the groups that were
partitioned and this looks at armed
conflict location and invent data
project the act led project and so it
includes all violent events a back leg
which is basically need 25 people killed
to get into a cloud or an event to get
into a cloud from 1997 to 201 3 and what
we see here is a really nice table that
the that the dense they are you getting
20% of the 20% of the non partition
groups having no conflict or having no
conflict in the a cloud database but for
the but for the partition group that
only 8% have had no conflict and you see
that the partition groups are much more
likely to be in conflict with the state
and and so this is in a sense a direct
you can say a direct effect of treaty
that did not involve the local
populations and you could even say it's
causal on conflict if we look at
development so we look at GDP per capita
205 and the the percent population in a
partition group and this is all
countries in the world but in the sense
being partitioned means being
partitioned means
lower growth to lower growth and higher
conflict number four
missionaries this can be a surprising
one so those of you who read the first
really great classic of post-it you can
say early independence literature and
China watch a base things fall apart
although acknowledging the anti modern
aspects of traditional religion he saw
the missionary activity as largely
destructive of community integrity Max
Weber in his essay now 110 years old and
as prizes and ethic and the spirit of
capitalism would lead us to expect there
was a treatment of Protestantism would
have a positive value for growth so can
we judge between these two I tell you
I'd rather read the chat bathe and Weber
but so we have from work by Robert
Woodbury and others we now have from
1923 missionaries per per 10,000
population and these are from just the
Africa part of the sample and we also
know where they were located and excuse
the humor in the second part of this but
for sub-saharan Africa basically per
10,000 population 0.65 for the rest of
the world one point one three
missionaries per 10,000 so they were
lower in sub-saharan Africa but we found
out that they do like the beach that if
you're an island country you I bridge to
per 10,000 as opposed non island point
five six that's what happens when you
give a graduate student some data you
you get these irrelevant associations I
couldn't take that one out though so
what we find in in sub-saharan Africa
and the rest of the world what you see
is that the number of missionaries per
cap in the world but also in Africa is
associated with higher levels with
higher levels of secondary school
enrollment 1960 1985 so higher levels of
human capital are associated with higher
levels of missionary presence what about
democracy
Woodberry makes this claim which is sort
of vibe Irian and that is that what the
missionaries did especially the
Protestants much more so than the
Catholics is they created newspapers and
demanded literacy why did they demand
literacy because the Protestants wanted
the their adherents to be able to read
the Bible which enabled them the
Africans who came out of missionary
schools to start writing newspapers
which were largely critical of the of
the colonial experience and and in the
sense created a civil society which is
one of the foundations for democracy and
so Woodberry sort of hypothesized that
post independence those who were more
exposed to missionary experience would
be would be in countries that would have
a higher poverty score that there's be
more democratic and the data give
limited support for this and we could
say this is partially exogenous that the
Africans didn't invite the the
missionaries there although there was
some bit of that because that where
missionaries were shot at they didn't go
and where they were welcomed
they they stayed and you could say where
they were welcome maybe political
cultures that were more cosmopolitan
more open to their own education and
change so it's not as exciting this as
one as a social scientist would want but
there is there is this association and
so we could say that in terms of human
capital and democracy the evidence
suggests Africa suffered from a relative
shortage of Protestant missionaries
rather than the destructive effect of
the missionaries that Chinua Achebe once
wanted us to to believe although I have
to say that HFA's novels much more
nuanced than that
yeah
so for those of for the rest of you what
the astronaut gluon Robinson point to is
that we're colonists were most subject
to disease that in the sense you didn't
get the building of rule of law
institutions so ones which are most
compatible for Europeans to impose their
the institutional project the the in the
sense the greater the greater the the
the development so you have what they
call the reversal of fortune those
places where like North America where
where Europeans could survive you get
extremely strong institutions those
which they had more difficult surviving
in say West Africa you get you in the
sense get you allow you allow the locals
to oppress their own populations don't
impose European institutions and you get
worse outcomes this is a highly
controversial in the field in law in
large part because they actually never
showed you the institutions that were
being built so there are only
hypothesized institutions but this is a
long debate the colonial state I think I
said in the first lecture that that the
colonial state is often pointed to as
the culprit and colonialism as the
culprit for all that went bad but it's
extraordinarily difficult to actually
identify the effect of the colonial
state if everyone had it and whether is
it about the colonial state what are the
mechanisms of the colonial state and
once you start looking at this carefully
the colonial state existed that say from
1885 to 1960
like the whole history of Africa and and
and so in the sense great books like
Crawford Young's book on the on the
African colonial state describe or
describe some of the worst excesses of
colonialism but can't identify what
those excesses excesses were on outcomes
we care about so one we could see if
Libya Liberian at the opie are
substantially different without having
been with having fully experienced
colonial rule by European states but
it's hard to get inferential leverage
from two cases out of fifty some some
odd and and the degree to which you
could say Ethiopia and Liberia were not
really colonized well that's an
ambiguous kind of claim to make and no
one is taking a Liberia or Ethiopia
dummy variable and saying you see there
was no effect of colonialism
second you can reconstruct the
counterfactual through pre-colonial
state building trends in Africa and I'm
going to do that for the next couple of
slides and the third point I'll get back
to in a few minutes so this is something
that really doesn't have any good
statistical sort of support but I think
there's something to it going back to
work of Richard Reid with a military
revolution in 19th century proto states
were all in the making and Reid says
looking throughout the African continent
in a wonderful book points out that
there was a military revolution in
Africa in the mid 19th century where
proto states were in the making that is
those groups that could project power
were actually creating units which were
state like and you see in the Dom a
Ashante ibadan and West Africa the rise
of the Bureau state and today's Uganda
mingo knee and zulu armies conquering
new territories in South Africa and both
London foe do building a
large affective Caliphate in Sokoto in
northwestern Nigeria and his causal
conjecture was that the colonial
authorities and classic amongst them
Lord Lu guard who served as as colonial
weathers that the colonial governor in
Uganda and in Nigeria his basic idea was
the way to govern these territories was
to find people who had high legitimacy
that is Chiefs and give them salaries
that is give them authority to keep the
peace and instead of banking on the
emergent state military state units
which were largely transit ethnic and
highly merit-based you went back to
traditional based leaders and gave them
the support to rule over areas in a
sense this undermined the the enormous
ly creative state building processes of
the 19th century and created a bunch of
states whose made whose leaders has an
interest in the status quo so the causal
conjecture is the colonial authorities
sought control in the cheap and
reinstalled traditional leadership or
you're over ibadan for example because
ibadan didn't have a great king but it
had the best army and you support you
support the most legitimate king rather
than the most authoritative army and
this brought order at the expense of
dynamic development the third way to
look at identify the effect of colonial
state and post-colonial African
development is to ask whether is there's
a single colonial effect but Crawford
young calls
bula Matadi the colonial state as a
crusher of stones bulam mitering is sort
of the metaphor throughout crawford
young's book or whether we can leverage
differences in the colonial experience
to see if the type of colonial rule
the causal effect on development
outcomes so let's look at the returns to
the lock of assignment at the Treaty of
Berlin it's not so much luck Chris will
get me on this one so if you look at
doctors per capita university education
and that where would you rather be who
would you rather be ruled by here the
average primary plus secondary Portugal
wins out but that's almost all on
primary and almost none on secondary so
if you look at secondary over primary
Britain would be way on top again so
when the creation of governing elite you
could say also a medical elite and we
saw some of the effects of the medical
elite in the Ebola crisis where Nigeria
which can't put down an insurgency in a
northeast the medical the medical
profession was trusted in ways that did
not occur in in Sierra Leone and in
Liberia for infrastructure phones
railroads per square mile and vehicles
again again Britain does extremely
better in in basic infrastructure civil
war within three years of Independence
what we find is that Belgian two out of
three
Portugal two out of five and France and
Britain practically none and here's a
case where institution well I have to
take a step back Farren and I basically
asked the question from a statistical
point of view that whether the factors
associated with Civil War onset post
1945 and one of the robust variables
that are you could call predictors
although we may had no causal
identification was whether the country
was independent within
the past three years and early
independence was a big predictor
basically from a fear on point of view
that minorities when a country becomes
independent minorities face a difficult
dilemma that they're likely to be
oppressed by the new majority but the
new majority won't depress them until
they're strong enough to do so it takes
a few years to be able to to get your
army to be able to oppress so you have a
small window of two or three years to
get the hell out of that country and so
in a sense like the you can think of the
classic case of the Serbs in the cria in
in Croatia that before the COTS figure
out how to get rid of the Serbs you
might as well try to get your
independence early so in the sense the
first two or three years are ones where
the state is the weakest and they say
that's the weakest and the opportunities
for rebellion there for the greatest and
what you find is in Africa that the
French and British armies didn't leave
and help protect the new leadership in
those early years but when Portugal and
Belgium got out they got out in nineteen
forties in the sense in the in the the
the with the Ottoman Empire the Brits
got out as fast as they could for both
India and in Middle East with the same
effects of the first two years being
disastrous so in a sense Britain and
France were stronger colonial powers
able to manage a transition to
independence much better than the other
colonial leaders if you look at economic
growth and this connects to the
investments in infrastructure in
education each line is a different
country you see that Britain outpaced
Belgium Portugal and France except for I
believe I'm pretty sure that's got boom
back to Robinson sorry back to Ashley mo
glue and in Robinson if you look at
legislative institutions that is the
number of years before independence that
you had a legislative council that you
had Native representative in the
Legislative Council or you has elected
native representation in Legislative
Council what we see is that the UK that
is sorry that UK starts earlier has more
countries with earlier legislative
institutions
this is Senegal which is very early for
the at least the four communes of
Senegal so in the sense early
institutional development early
infrastructural investment pays off for
UK colonies and we look at the regime
type we see that on the polity score
that on average being a colony of
Britain pays off or paid off not only
for economic growth but for but for
democracy so all colonial states to
achieve order undermine the state
building gains of Africa's military
revolution that's yet to be demonstrated
but the historical work suggests that
hypothesis but once colonized I say
fewer stones were crushed or more seeds
planted under British colonial rule
cultural diversity I explained earlier
what at the linguistic fractionalization
or early election but ethnic linguistic
fractionalization means it is if you
take two people randomly from any
country the probability they will have a
different cause ethno-linguistic
heritage and it's a dispersion index
that those of you who want to do the
arithmetic that's the algorithm but that
will basically get you from from zero
which says that zero probability someone
will be of a different ethnic group to
0.99 a 99% chance that two people will
be of different ethnic groups and that
would be hard to achieve or no one would
be able to communicate with one another
so this this e.l.f ethnic linguistic
fractionalization has been pointed to by
several economists and it goes it goes
again and again in the literature that
Africa's growth tragedy has associated
with high levels of ethno-linguistic
fractionalization so if you look at a
tlf and latitude what we find is Els in
the census is predicted by latitude and
that's something if you read the
literature on on sort of ecology you
find it's exactly the same for all plant
species and all animal species the Koshu
are the equator the more diverse them
the more ecological diversity you get
and it fits it fits linguistic variation
just about perfectly although no one has
a clue as to why and also so
it may be the e.l.f factor may be
confounded confounded by latitude
also in a amazing paper by Stelios
McCullough Poulos also is associated
with soil diversity that what he does is
looks at soil nickel a post as he looks
at soil diversity by made-up country he
calls them virtual countries he divides
the world up into squares or is it
squares or rectangles I forget but
something like a square and then looks
at the degree to which there is soil
diversity in that Square and then looks
at a LF within that Square and then
looks at production in that Square and
finds that once you put soil diversity
the effect of ethnic linguistic
diversity disappears remarkable paper so
in other words the exigent negati of
e.l.f has not has been slowly undermined
by recent research nonetheless I think
there's something still to be told about
the LF but not a whole lot and then we
show you why not a whole lot from work
that I've done with fear on this is
going to be somewhat unreadable but I'll
try my best to explain what this is but
it's in 203 American polka science
review here we have on the x-axis GDP
from poor to rich here we have degree of
ethnic homogeneity high low and this is
the proportion of share of the largest
cultural group it's not really a LF it's
the size of the largest at the group is
the same thing with occur and let's take
let's take the relatively the relatively
the proportion of ethnic group if you're
if you're a poor the probably these are
all the probabilities of a civil war
onset over a five-year period so over
five year period its 0.14 here 0.18 it
goes up slightly as you get more
for poor countries as you get more
homogeneous here if you're a rich
country it actually goes down and
there's no consistent pattern of the the
no consistent pattern at any level of
GDP for the probability of civil war but
if you go this way and say as you go say
at near a hundred percent of the one
ethnic group the richer you get start up
at point three down to zero for highly
heterogeneous groups twenty four point
one to point all 5.00 to so in a sense
ethnic heterogeneity does not predict
civil war onset one of the big findings
of research I've done with fear on is
that is that the capability of the state
as as indicated by proxy by by GDP is
washes out Els washes out any ethnic
kind of algorithm or percentage in
predicting civil war
similarly with low levels of conflict
you get a slightly slightly positive
coefficient that holds up in most kind
of metric specifications but it's
somewhat fragile that as e.l.f goes up
that is as you have more
fractionalization you get slightly more
slightly more a probability of low level
conflict twenty five deaths so there's
some relationship to violence and ethnic
heterogeneity but not a whole lot we
know from the world however that ethnic
fractionalization is associated with
lower GDP but that isn't well identified
that's merely association which may be
torn apart when you look at the
diversity of soil quality or or
from the equator so the easterly Lavigne
finding about e.l.f and Africa's growth
the tragedy is not entirely convincing
but if you just take a LF and ask what's
the effect of e.l.f on the delivery of
public goods that is things in which
everyone collectively has to pay for and
anyone collectively can enjoy that is
goods like a good school system or a
lighthouse or wells for the whole
community and here we're getting some
real traction for e.l.f and this is work
by Miguel and Kruger the in in Kenya I
gave some of this material in the in the
second lecture but basically what they
do is in in Busia in in in western Kenya
they take each school district or each
small district and code that as to how
diverse it is that is there are two or
three different ethnic groups in western
Kenya which haven't moved for a hundred
years because of British policy not
prohibiting movement of populations for
a long time so in a sense the the
diversity of the population they argue
is exogenous and as people would have
moved to richer areas if they could have
but they couldn't under the colonial
system and so in Busia but you have are
relatively stable ethnic proportions for
a long time and then what they do is
they look to see on two outcomes which
are public goods one contributions to
the school system without these sort of
voluntary contributions the school
systems would have almost no materials
and these are called harambe let us pull
together
Harambee school donations second there
was a finish F
from Finland a project of building wells
throughout this whole region and and the
Finns built in this in a few places in
the region places where you can get
spare parts and repairs and what they
found what they wanted to ask is for
these two public goods school system and
well maintenance
well maintenance in the sense is a
public good because you can't exclude
anybody from it and in the sense it's
not rival that there's anyone who uses
it does not stop the next person from
gaining from it so they're their actual
true public goods and what they find is
that areas with average ethnic
linguistic fractionalization are six
percentage points less likely to have a
functioning well in homogeneous areas
and of course they control for how how
far away you are from Lake Victoria and
all sorts of other factors which might
have intervened here too if you can get
if you're close enough to Lake you and
the well doesn't work instead of going
to get it repaired you can go to you can
go to the lake so all these things were
controlled and still a big effect of
ethnic heterogeneity unwell maintenance
and for local school funding average
local school funding with average e.l.f
is 20 percent less than in homogeneous
areas so people are less willing to to
act for the community to the degree to
which the community is ethnically
diverse and Africa's therefore high
ethnic diversity is having an
independent independent effect on low
low levels of the production of public
goods why is this an ethnic exclusion
actually the jury is still out there's
not much evidence that ethnic exclusion
is doing the work that the loo years are
keeping the tezo's from their schools or
or anything of that sort differing
preferences know you do a survey and you
find that everyone wants the well to
work they all want someone else to do it
though and they
want better schools it's not like some
have suggested the ethnic heterogeneity
you can't agree on anything because
people want different things but most
people want better schools and wells
that work
what about inability to coordinate
there's mixed evidence on this that if
you speak a different language and that
you have different social networks it's
harder to in the sense reach agreements
with people who speak different
languages
even though Swahili may be an inter away
- or English may be a way to to mediate
this but that the inability to
coordinate seems not to be a big effect
on other research throughout Africa and
a great book on Co ethnicity by Hobby
Romana
and others shows only the inability to
coordinate has a small effect whereas
these first two have no effects it's
this one which Miguel finds for his
Busia
research and happier mana and all find
in their research in Uganda and that is
but they call weak monitoring and that
is that if you're a principal of a
school how can I can make a Yale and now
what you hear or something that the
those of you who are undergraduates will
soon find that your common Yale identity
will be appeal to every year as they as
they beg you for money and and what's
interesting about this is they at least
were similar school where I was uh
educated they have a class president
whose job is to humiliate you if you
haven't given and there are various
humiliation strategies and one of them
of course is to list the people who are
on the honor honor let's call the code
do whatever that is who've given more
than a certain amount of money and you
look to see oh this person is given a
lot and you see your name way down there
and your
Mille ate it and you think what's the
least I can give to not be humiliated my
father used to do that with a UGA JEA so
I knew the strategy very well so so that
if you're in the school suggests Miguel
and cougar they and there are different
ethnic groups humiliation is dangerous
people may think they're you're doing it
to them because you're @s oh and not
because you're a laggard in payment it
could lead to all sorts of
misunderstandings and that we find in
experimental games throughout Africa
that the degree to which you're being
watched by a member of your own ethnic
group leads to higher levels of support
for public goods and in the sense being
watched by someone from another ethnic
group does not have the same effect so
in the sense there is a there is a in
the sense weak monitoring in of weak
monitoring in the in the in the giving
of support for public goods the the
weaker monitoring the degree to which
there is ethnic linguistic
fractionalization so for cultural
diversity africa's diversity in part
through the latitude soil diversity and
to the partition i think still has an
independent the fact may be a low-level
violent conflict maybe on growth but i
think importantly on public goods types
war and Charles Tilly Charles Tilly's
famous states make Wars and Wars make
states has implications for
post-colonial State Building in Africa
the colonial wars were fought in Africa
appear to be reverse from Tilly the wars
were undermining future State Building
and I'm gonna argue the OAU organization
of African Unity bargain sustains what
Jackman and Rosburg called juridical
states whose leaders do not have
sufficient and sent
to build de facto states so this cool
thing comes from my collaborator Jim
fear on on the four types of wars in the
car lots of war data set non-state wars
fought by tribes or ethnic groups within
countries intra state wars which are
civil wars extra state wars which are
imperialist wars and interstate Wars
wars between states what we basically
find in this graph is that there was a
reversal in the second half of the 20th
century first half of the 20th century
about five deaths to interstate war for
one death and intrastate Wars in Reverse
in the in the second half of the 20th
century where almost all the deaths are
intrastate Wars and here in the mid and
late 19th century you have a whole
number of these extra state Wars which
were largely Wars of imperial conquest
so we have different types of wars and
we can ask the tilly question what types
of wars are associated with
state-building and what types of wars
are associated with state undermining
and in research that's still in progress
I'm doing with fear on we look at from
two data sets correlates of war and this
guy Paul breca who was now our Dean at
Georgia State University who went back
to the 1400s and I've coated every type
of war and every continent for how many
centuries it's back to the fourteen
we've only gone back to 1815 and the key
finding is what predicts post-civil war
civil conflict years the number of years
a country is in war post 1945 and with a
whole number of controls pre forty-five
imperialist conflict years is a
predictor of post forty-five civil war
years the effect is not gigantic but
it's but it's statistically significant
and substantively important and
you could say finding imperialist wars
in a sense were state undermining I'll
give you one example so when the Suez
Canal was built Aden which is now in the
news quite regularly became a coaling
station for the Brits but the Brits
couldn't get any meat from there and
they found that you get meat from
Berbers that is from from nomads in
Somalia to just to supply the coaling
station and basically nomads would come
up from the oka den area here to to
today's Berber and sell their goats and
even camels and and and that would go
off to Aden and then there was a
religious guy here Muhammad Abdullah
Hassan who who saw this as the end the
end of a Somali culture and also the end
of Islamic he thought that the
missionaries would come and turn them
all into Christians and he for the 21
year war against the Brits it was only
after world was started in 1899 and it
was not after it was only after World
War 1 where the Brits used their war
planes to bomb his his Center in tower
in today's Ethiopia was a 21 year old 21
year war were the oka den Center mostly
Dorado garden were fighting with
Mohammed Abdullah Hassan and the Brits
basically hired the e socked over here
the trading groups here to fight in
their armies so we had two armies that
developed over 21 years and you could
say that this imperialist war as an
example of an appearance work giving we
would call the conflict capital in
Somalia to be able to kill each other
once they were independent the
organization of African Unity is another
you could say
state building a state building problem
with the problem of what Rosburg and and
and Jackman call juridical states as
many of you know the organization of
African Unity from 1963 to 202 basically
made an agreement and that is to defend
their sovereignty their territorial
integrity and their independence this
third point was this third point was the
key and and that in many ways it's been
argued that Africa civil wars can be
considered State Building Wars can
Africa's civil wars be considered State
Building words wars in the tilly sense
but now I'm trending on
Nicholas's territory so I'm a little
nervous here but about 30 percent of
Africa's civil wars do not reward the
side that has been best projected power
with the right to rule thereby
undercutting the tilly mechanism of how
Wars make states this this point
political scientists sardonically call
give war a chance if if you allow the
the the in the sense the institutional
unit to that's most able to project
power to actually take power you might
be able to get States which and the
sense can rule over their own periphery
so consider the influence of the United
Nations Department of peacekeeping
operations and it's successful according
to the really terrific work of Doyle and
some badness and Michael Doyle who gave
the lectures a few years before me has
actually consolidated this into a
terrific book what they call
multi-dimensional peacekeeping missions
and what we find is if we look at
centers seeking civil wars and autonomy
seeking civil wars that basically 23% of
the center's seeking civil wars and 30%
of the autonomy seeking civil wars end
up with a kind of
non-type reconciliation of power sharing
and therefore in the sense tons of lives
were saved through this intervention of
basically United Nations Department of
peacekeeping operations but you might
say that although they find pretty
convincingly that these
multi-dimensional peacekeeping and peace
building processes do hold back war for
a significant period that is their life
saving what you need to show is their
state building and one could argue that
the UN system which is so successfully
saving lives may be undermining the
Tilly effect of war making states so we
could say from the Imperial in the 19th
century to cauterize civil wars in post
independence many of Africa's Wars have
not been State Building but have been
state undermining economic doctrines
well I want to argue here is you could
say that Africa's Independence of the
early 1960s just coincided with reigning
economic doctrines and a cold war which
had a big effect on economic policy on
the negative side
bad timing you could say African
socialism was one of three fateful
influences distorting economic
incentives the notion of import
substitution industrialization graining
at the time as the way to develop had
consequences which were quite harmful
for development and then foreign aid in
the Cold War era so at a dinner as I
mentioned and question and answer in the
first lecture in in crew Mizanur during
his visit to Cote d'Ivoire
few years before cote ivoire is
independent hoof weighed one ye the
future president of cote ivoire offered
this challenge at the dinner a wager has
been made between two territories one
having chosen independence the other
preferring the difficulty difficult road
to construct to the construction with
the Metropole of a community of men in
equal rights and duties let us each
undertake his experiment in absolute
respect of the experiment of his
neighbor and in 10 years in 10 years we
shall compare the results no there no
just go the results oh I should say here
countries the countries were neighbors
with similar resource endowments with
potential and cash crops cocoa and
coffee
they were dominant dominant cultivators
were small holding peasants the big
differences were the economic policies
at the implementations and time of
Independence Ghana's socialism cote
ivoire is accommodation to world
capitalism so it was a nice experiment
that hoof way had had given to us with
with his wager and crema was the loser
see IV is cote ivoire and although it
started off with 1960 with lower GDP per
capita was the loser but african
socialism or the idea of socialism was
so attractive in 1960 as an in the sense
the reason why the soviet union the
reason why China was able to catch up
was because of state socialism and the
only voice negative was an American
economist Eliot Berg who basically said
for socialism to work you actually need
a very effective state being able to do
Leon T of kind of matrix algebra and
being able to organize state with
enormous ly committed and well-educated
bureaucracy and without that there's no
way to do the [ __ ] to implement the
five-year plans which would make that
the Soviet Union relevant but Elliot
Berg got into American Economic Review
but not much else
and you could look at Botswana
because when Botswana becomes
independent everyone is laughing at them
for for giving up entirely the socialist
idea making fun of it and it's been the
fastest growing state in Africa so being
in the sense and the wrong the wrong the
wrong side of history when the reigning
economic doctrine was rather harmful the
World Bank as easterly has shown had
their own ideas about what brought about
economic development and as easterly
points out in a book about five years
ago that World Bank before the years was
unwilling to update the fact that it's
prescriptions were working negatively
rather than positively but Rowell
premise of the Economic Commission for
Latin America pushed this key to
development is quick moving out of raw
material dependence and the best
industrial policy is to manufacture
goods that meet domestic demand through
substitution
why did is I fail the economic doctrine
of 1960 supported policies that taxed
the peasantry in order to build
manufacturing that would substitute for
imports in Ghana
what taxing the peasantry meant was in
marketing boards you underpaid the
peasants for their cocoa and what did
the peasants do they just moved to ivory
coast and sold it they're enhancing hoof
ways tax base and undermining Ghana's
the low wages in the new industries
though in order to make your import
substitution work you had to have low
wages but the way you supported that was
exchange rate policies which overvalued
local currencies but once you do that as
Bates's work shows these policies
undermined agricultural sectors who
couldn't in the sense peace be supported
or buy anything from their agricultural
gains and it created not
competitive manufacturing cent sectors
which were completely supported by the
phony exchange rate economic doctrines
in 1960s facilitated under development
in Africa let me say something about the
Cold War I'm gonna give you two slides
one from Vreeland and draft and one from
drug the African Development Bank
pre-1982
was basically internally funded in
Africa after 1982 it got funds from the
OECD states the rich states and what we
find to make a long story short is if
you were a United Nations Security
Council member pre-1982 it had no
relationship whatsoever to how many
grants or how much funding you got
through the development bank but
post-1980 to suddenly if you were on the
Security Council didn't matter what the
value of your project the African
Development Bank was sensitive and what
real and then Dreier do is say let's
take the years in which there were
crucial votes in the Security Council
which of course is exactly anything
Africans would be interested in and it
finds out that this coefficient is even
more powerful so in a sense foreign aid
was going for licking the behinds of the
of Western Western countries rather than
for projects which were in the sense
economically viable under the George W
Bush years they developed this
millennial Development Fund where they
try to eliminate this variable are you
voting with the United Nations the
United States and the Security Council
and try to say institutional development
and institutional integrity was going to
be the key to whether you get any money
this this program has been extremely
difficult to implement and it's still
won over the jury is out whether it has
any return what we find from the work of
- of j-rod
is that that if you just look at
non-strategic a that there's
non-military aid and changes in infant
mortality that the countries with bad
institutions that is who get most of
their money from oil or other windfalls
banned institutions the in the sense the
aid has zero effect on things we care
about in this case in this case infant
mortality it's only the countries that
have had to build decent institutions in
which the age has worked so you could
say aid policies
going to countries which are not
building institutions in the sense which
is basically a Cold War kind of a Cold
War effect has had a big effect in
rewarding countries for kissing the
behind of the OECD rather than building
institutions that would enhance their
development so the economic
disincentives growth socialism without
the state apparatus to manage an economy
this is Elliott Berg's point import
substitution disincentivizes agriculture
and supports inefficient industry and
foreign aid goes to Western clients with
no incentive to make that aid work so
you could say the economic doctrines and
the Cold War and an independent effect
on Africa's development so the eight
causal accounts geography and demography
the slave trade the partition
missionaries the colonial state e.l.f a
cultural diversity international support
of juridical states and the prevailing
economic doctrines and cold war at time
of independence this as much as we know
to explain why Africa has led the rest
of the world in development in in after
optimistic optimistic moment of the
early 1960s I can't stop there
there are manifold causes for the
dysfunctional politics in Africa
post-independence but people can remake
their own histories and indeed there are
some hopeful signs that Africa has
already begun turning a corner 20 years
of democracy in multiracial South Africa
that in my generation no one believed
that post apartheid South Africa would
be both democratic and and functioning
not that they don't have problems but
two functioning and and establish
democracy that's one of the great
achievements I think of the end of the
20th century
there's trends of better scores on
transparency executive constraints
throughout Africa the two keys to in the
sense predicting economic growth both
predicting better property rights and
stronger growth economies of sub-saharan
Africa grew with a strong pace of 4.5% a
year on average during the 1995 to 2013
even though per capita income growth was
modest at around 2% but still compared
to the 1980s and early 1990s Africa has
clearly turned a corner malaria and
measles even though they haven't reached
levels that the rest of the world has
achieved as I showed in the first
lecture the road we're on the road to
extinction of these diseases in Africa
so Africa remains even with these
hopeful signs Africa remains as the
world's final frontier
while they've been examples of progress
I believe it is up to next generations
of Africans and Friends of Africa to
bring to their populations the quality
of life and governance that's the right
of all people thank you very much
that literature is one which is creating
every paper comes out more ambiguity but
I will say that people have asked the
question why why diamonds in Sierra
Leone versus diamonds in Botswana and so
the standard answer amongst African Asst
or people who study this thing is Sierra
Leone has these alluvial diamonds which
means that anybody with a small militia
can in the sense harvest it and
therefore you have the shadow States
with shadow militias each each having
established sort of rights or property
rights to exploitation of these alluvial
fields whereas Botswana it's deep down
with high capital investment and
therefore can't be stolen every day by a
small small militia so it was a luck
that you needed high high capital
investment there but to actually think
in the terms of well kevo is rich in
rich in diamonds that means this sorry
rich in a bunch of minerals which means
you have Rwanda and Uganda and Kinshasa
all seeking out control over this region
but we did some research and said on
this question and said if you can find
areas which have high value is it more
likely people will be fighting over it
over the past 150 years and we couldn't
find any relationship so it's still in
the air
I Sam Huntington came out with this
youth bulge paper similar 20 years ago
or something and it's a great idea
except I've seen no support for it I
find that that unemployment is
endogenous two other factors and and you
could think that Japan's growth would be
much greater if in fact it had some of
those youth so in the sense that if you
have a dynamic economy youth is a really
good thing but we find we find no
evidence of youth bulge on the
probability of civil war or on anything
that we absolutely care about and so I
still see it in the newspapers all the
time people like Tom Friedman right
there by there every two weeks but but I
actually don't say I have I actually
have not seen empirical support for it
well that makes it hard to test Chris
well I read the literature
I haven't actually put this in any of
the work I've done because we've we've
been using national states as unit of
analysis and then using standard
standard pen pen world tables but it's
so attractive to be able to say if
you're if you're within if you're within
50 years of 50 miles of the border as
opposed to being near the capital city
and then things like Posner does looks
at who's the effort what's the ethnic
group of the leader
where will the electricity lines go and
it's amazingly predictive of where the
electricity the lines go it but but that
the the outcome variable is not growth
it's it's its rewards for being in the
write-up in the group so this is
problematic and but it's it's but this
satellite data is too exciting not to
not to use even if we're not entirely
sure whether it's measuring yes
so states are reflected in polity scores
and so when I say democracy as the
outcome variable one party one party
states with some degree of executive
constraints tend to wire you up in this
zone which I've called an accuracy
somewhere between minus 5 and plus 5 so
I'm seeing when part of the states are
observing one-party States as an outcome
for which we're seeking to explain that
is lower levels lower the lower levels
of democracy and greater difficulty of
opposition opposition groups to
coordinate against the incumbent so on
average in elections in the last 20
years or so I forgot exactly what the
timescale was but on average the number
to party in African elections has been
about 0.25 which means that most
elections are non-competitive hegemonic
parties or you can say one party's de
facto one-party states and the question
becomes why don't you get coordination
of the opposition especially when the
dominant group or the or the ruling
group is effectively governing and the
Oh areola has the best book on answering
this question and looks at the cases
where you do get effective opposition
and as I've argued in the first lecture
only if you get effective opposition
will you get some degree of
accountability of of governing groups
second lecture my idea was these are the
symptoms the coos and and the and the
lack of opposition but not causal in the
sense that they're endogenous to the to
two factors that I try to outline today
thank you